well we're seeing an increase in these
journeys being made during the summer
because the weather just makes that
perilous journey that tiniest bit easier
now it's still incredibly dangerous many
people are making journeys up to 10
hours across the world's busiest
shipping lane in small boats and small
dinghies that aren't equipped for the
journey and it's led to a record number
on saturday 828 either being rescued or
intercepted when crossing the channel
and eventually arriving here
and also in france authorities there
intercepted around 193
people it's been a record year around 12
and a half migrants have entered the uk
and this year and when putting that into
context last year it was just under
eight and a half thousand so a really
big increase and it's something the
government have said that they are
looking into they have pledged to fix
what they've called the broken asylum
system already 55 million pounds has
been given to france
to get french authorities to double
their uh their police officers
patrolling beaches there and pretty
patel's also said she has plans to
increase the prison sentences for people
entering the uk illegally but many are
desperate to make this journey in search
of a better life and no doubt they will
continue to do that despite this